the scenes of chaos at the capitol
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
what we're seeing are a small number of
extremists
dedicated to lawlessness this is not
dissent
it's disorder it's chaos
it borders on sedition and it must
end now
i call on this mob to pull back and
allow the work of democracy to go
forward
you've heard me say before in different
contexts
the words of a president matter
no matter how good or bad that president
is
at their best the words of a president
can inspire
at their worst they can incite
and therefore i call on president trump
to go on national television now
to fulfill his oath and defend the
constitution
and demand an end to this siege
to storm the capital to smash windows
to occupy offices the floor of the
united states senate
rummaging through desks on the capitol
on the
house of representatives threatening the
safety of duly elected officials it's
not
protest it's insurrection
the world's watching like so many other
americans
i am genuinely shocked and saddened that
our nation
so long the beacon of light and hope for
democracy
has come to such a dark moment